bonsoir comment allez vous ça va très
bien merci vous y sommes en voie le port
de montréal alors le port de montréal
qui est tjrs est bon on garde le cap
évidemment on a eu un très bon début
d'année mais qui va maintenant être
suivie de quelques mois qui vont être
certainement plus difficile en termes de
volume notre premier trimestre comme je
disais était vraiment très bon qui
suivait une année 2009 qui était une
sixième année record consécutive
mais là vous savez on est toujours un
peu al avance de ce qui se passe dans
les marchés donc présentement c'est là
que nous allons voir une diminution en
fait on s'attend à une diminution
d'environ 12%
si je compare à l'année 2019 pour
l'ensemble de nos trafics avec une
petite remontée vers la fin de l'année
alors ça devrait aller mieux à la fin de
l'année donc on dit toujours que les
activités portuaires est un peu le
baromètre de l'économie votre baromètre
nous dit que les prochains mois seront
difficiles dans l'économie absolument
c'est ce qu'on nous dit donc on a vu
depuis quelques semaines que le niveau
d'exportation avec ont commencé à
diminuer
et là c'est les importations qui diminue
un petit peu évidemment vous le savez on
est importe diversifiée je vous parle
l'eau des conteneurs mais si je regarde
les vracs liquides aussi avec moins de
consommation moins de carburant pour les
avions les voitures et aussi notre
trafic de croisière évidemment ça c'est
beaucoup plus difficile on s'attend une
baisse beaucoup plus importante en fait
presque pas de saison aussi en eux une
pour 2020 parce que les croisières feu
reprend seulement après le 1er juillet
exact mais une fiche compagnie et déjà
les compagnies qui ont annulé toute la
saison
donc il nous reste à peu près un volume
de 20 pour cent vingt mille passagers
pardon sur le centaine de milles qu'on
aurait attendu donc on verra s'ils vont
vraiment venir on l'espère mais opéra et
je reviens sur les conteneurs est ce que
des conteneurs qui s'empilent plein de
stocks et d'inventaire en ce moment
compte tenu que l'économie bouge
beaucoup et rapidement
non on est absolument très très fluide
les contenants qui rendent chez nous
ressorte et ceux qui arrivent
n'attendent pas sur les quais sont
immédiatement embarqué dans les na'vi
on a cru sa maman donne hélas que ça
pourrait arriver parce que beaucoup
d'entre eux pour son plein où étaient
fermés mais au contraire les entreprises
se sont organisés de la place pour faire
circuler les contenants et on est 100%
opérationnel grâce à tous nos excellents
travailleurs et on y suit est ce que la
logistique et le transit des
marchandises pu être ce que ledit dans
les dernières semaines être compromis
être fragilisé à un certain moment
écoutez je vous dirai pas vraiment parce
que on sait on la chaîne logistique
c'est vraiment concertée on a travaillé
ensemble et ce qui est arrivé c'est
évidemment si les entrepôts étaient
fermés l'aca a pu créer un problème de
livraison mais c'était pas autour du
paon ce n'était pas dans la la partie où
je dirais navire même pas camion train
c'est plus vers les entrepôts que ça a
été plus difficile mais on peut dire
qu'on fonctionne même encore c est
difficile ça coûte plus cher mais on
fonctionne à la normalité
quel rôle vous jouez le port de montréal
à la relance la réouverture de
l'économie j'ai vous savez on est un
moteur économique je pense important
dans montréal les villes portuaires
connaissent de développement économique
toujours plus important que les autres
villes on est aussi attractif pour
plusieurs entreprises qui vont venir s'y
intéresser
ce qu on est intéressés à s'installer
autour du port donc ça va continuer à
jouer ce rôle là évidemment par les
investissements que l'on fait on
investit dans des projets
d'infrastructure de façon soutenue
depuis plusieurs années donc là on a un
peu ralenti la cadence compte tenu de la
baisse de revenus qu'on anticipe mais
quand même il ya plusieurs projets qui
ont même repris lé avec le retour des
employés de la construction
on va donc continuer d'investir avec nos
partenaires évidemment pro par aussi
notre grand projet de terminal à
conteneurs à contrecoeur qui de toute
évidence à sa place parce que dès que
savoir apprendre on va être fin prêt des
gens pourraient débuter en double et des
propos a besoin départ at war vous avez
décidé de repousser votre e départ à la
retraite vous deviez deux parties là ou
presque le gt était effectivement on
avait annoncé en janvier que dans
quelques mois j'aurais titre est pour la
retraite mais compte tenu des
circonstances
j'ai rapidement avec le conseil la
discussion pas été longue pris la
décision d'accompagner mes collègues
dans cette douce il traverse et puis
j'ai remis mon projet plus tard bon ce
sera meilleur plus tard sylvie vachon
merci beaucoup merci mais ses clients en
soirée